I mean you've always played with the
idea of retiring like I've heard you say
multiple times this is my last album
yeah I feel like that every time I do an
album
because like so many opportunities open
up for me when I do each album you know
I mean like I did Alfredo so many like
the film opportunities start opening up
for me you know what I mean you know I
mean dude you're doing stand-up like
exactly so you're walking in Austin
comedy stand-up comedy distant rappers
on stand-up comedy you know you ever
been discing a stand-up routine
I don't even got a rap about you listen
it's really rough to go like like I
would just say this like and this is not
to anyone in particular but like if
there was a single person I wouldn't
want to like get into some internet [ __ ]
with it be you because oh yeah you're
[ __ ] because you're the funniest
rapper because I'm gonna turn it into
comedy bed I'm gonna turn everything
into so funny man because it's all jokes
to me you know what I'm saying like you
know we can laugh about all of this [ __ ]
the whole time you know what I'm saying
to you you know try to get physical but
other than that like you know you know
like [ __ ] try to play with me
and I'll just make their ass and I turn
their ass into memes as academics you
know what I'm saying like and like I
said I don't even know him like that
either I probably met him like once or
twice but you know it seemed like he got
everything in the world to say about me
and that's cool they've been he's been a
big
promotional Force for me these past two
years so thank you academics I
appreciate you do you feel like there
was a important time during the
academics thing maybe you're putting a
little too much energy into act not at
all I just dissed them the other day on
Flex what you mean because I ain't never
ain't never too much energy ain't no
ain't no ain't never too much energy
into a [ __ ] that talk about your girl
your family ain't never too much yeah it
ain't never too much energy [ __ ] You're
Gonna Get You Gonna Get these
[ __ ] bullets whenever I shoot
them out figuratively of course yeah
yeah
I feel like I could sit down and talk to
the [ __ ] he ain't no like hell of a
[ __ ] he ain't like no [ __ ] you got to
be afraid of no no no so we could
probably have a conversation you know I
mean I I don't need to hurt him you know
I mean I don't need to like hit him or
no [ __ ] like that I don't I don't feel
that way because I don't feel that he's
any type of threat he's just a [ __ ]
that's posting about me on the [ __ ]
internet what the [ __ ] can you do to me
right I don't give a [ __ ] about that
yeah so I felt like if he was in the
room we could even talk and I'd be like
you wrong you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'ma say to all that [ __ ] to
your face and then I'm gonna like this
here's why and you can say how you feel
about me and here's why and that's that
and if you feel away about it after keep
it moving or fight or excuse me man we
still be cool after that
it's cool